i want to thank everyone for joining us
to celebrate the proudest moment in east
town sports history
and finally miss lady hawk herself
see this yet big write-up in the tribune
i'm gonna frame it hang it up in your
office
yeah please yeah my daughter's been
missing for exactly one year
and the police aren't doing anything
how's your mother doing
she's being the hero of all the houses
my ex-husbands move into he has to buy
the one right behind mine
i heard he got a really good deal
hey
[Music]
the east town police department received
a call reporting a dead body
in credon creek we've decided to bring
in a county detective to assist with the
case
how do you like working with my mom so
far we're just getting started out
take tips lower your expectations
should we do this outside no all right
let's go
hey whoa whoa what's up she knows what's
happening tony she knows
all right are you friends with these
people
yeah why do they call you lady hawk
i made a shot in a basketball game it
must have been some shot
around here yeah the terrible events of
this past
year have ravaged this community where
who did this you get the son of a [ __ ]
cause if you don't i'll kill him myself
i can't feel it this expectation from
people
to be something i don't think i'm good
enough to be
hey they think you're a hero
fail in the full there are a lot of
things i don't like but you're not a
fool
[Music]
it might be a good thing to step away i
know what you've been through
and i know you're worth saving
recommit yourself
i'm gonna find out everything
[Music]
everything
you